we've talked a good bit about how the
Chinese government is printing UN 2x4 in
exchange to keep the UN devalued but
what I want to do in this video is
actually look at the data and show you
that I wasn't making all of that stuff
up so this is actually data from the
People's Bank of China this is directly
from their website and right over here
this is the 2010 money supplies is the
2009 money supply you can get any money
supply any year that you want from their
site and what we could do is just look
at what happened over just even 2010 or
from the same point in oh 9 - oh 10 let
me take November oh 9 to November oh 10
and just I'll look at their m1 money
supply I'll look at it at their m1 money
supply and I'm going from November to
November because we'll see that some of
the other charts that's we actually have
data for there we don't have December in
December for some of the other charts
I'm going to use in this video but it
just gives the general idea if you go
from November of 2009 the m1 money
supply now this is in hundred million
yuan so there was a two hundred twelve
thousand four hundred ninety three
hundred million yuan and we'll try to
convert these into numbers that make a
little bit more sense and then you fast
forward to November of 2010 the m1 is
two hundred fifty nine thousand four
hundred twenty hundred million yuan so
if we let's get a calculator out and
actually make some sense of that so a
year later it's at 259 420 and from that
let's subtract what it was before two
hundred and twelve thousand four hundred
and ninety three so the difference is 46
thousand nine hundred and twenty seven
now this is in hundred million yuan so
if you wanted in million one you want to
multiply by a hundred I think it's
pronounced UN or you want I'm not a
Chinese pronunciation expert so that
gets us to for this gets it's this is in
millions of UN and now if we wanted in
billions we can divide this by a
thousand so let's divide this by a
thousand so it's roughly four point six
four point seven trillion UN increase in
there n once money supply from November
2009 to November 2010 so a pretty
dramatic increase and just so you could
put this in the scope of dollars I'll
use a rough approximation for the
current exchange rate six point five UN
per dollar so let me just divide that by
six point five to get a rough
approximation for what that would be in
dollars and we get 721 remember this was
in billion so we're actually 722 billion
dollar expansion in the m1 money supply
of China from November 2009 to November
2010 and the next video we're going to
see how this compares to their actual
increase in foreign exchange or actually
foreign assets and we can see how much
of this was actually just to go and go
buy things from other countries or bike
for an exchange from other current
countries and essentially to keep to
keep the Chinese when devalued this is
Salman Khan of the Khan Academy for CNBC